the friendly skies haven't always been
friendly for women or people of color
according to 2020 federal labor
statistics about 3 percent of
aircraft pilots and flight engineers are
black or african american and under six
percent are women one of the few women
pilots of color is carol hobson who
flies a boeing 737 for united
as a first officer and she was inspired
to become a pilot by the story of
another black woman bessie coleman the
first african-american woman to earn a
pilot's license now hopson has written a
book inspired by coleman one she hopes
can help her mission to diversify the
aviation industry
which way coming from coming from the
left look at that nose
very good in the cockpit soaring high
above carol hopson has relinquished the
pilot seat
she's mentored silver ford for the past
six years
where were you
before you met carol hopson before i met
carol i was a freshman at embry riddle
aeronautical university in daytona beach
florida honestly in the process of
going to classes trying to figure out
how i would afford flight training
tuition was approximately forty thousand
a year flight training
fees could be as much as twenty thousand
but ford is now an official flight
instructor and will soon become the
first black woman pilot in the tennessee
air national guard's 164th
airlift wing so your students come out
and fly here oh sure absolutely this is
one of our airplanes it's all possible
through the luke weathers flight academy
in olive branch mississippi
named after the tuskegee airmen and
first african-american air traffic
controller so my role is a cheerleader
my role is to help bring awareness of
the school to fundraise in order to get
a hundred black women through flight
school we estimate it's gonna be about
seven million dollars courtney gillespie
is one of them when she met hopson she
was working as a lifeguard to pay off a
six-figure student loan from her time in
aviation school she said look you're
going to have to make a plan but i have
somewhere where you can probably go
that's going to help you out but you're
going to have to make a way to get there
and so when she finally gave me like
that little light at that end of the
tunnel that kind of where i can start to
see my journey going i really took it i
took it i grabbed onto it this nonprofit
program cuts flight training costs by
two-thirds thanks to hobson and her
fellow members of the organization of
black aerospace professionals including
captain albert glenn i'd like for you to
meet michelle mueller michelle this is
my mentor he mentored you when you see
her mentoring other students how does
that feel it feels great because you
know it's that finding those diamonds
and then watching them shine you know
and given the opportunity and being able
to put together school and then being
able to put monies
you know in the hands of those who need
it
to be successful is it was a dream as a
united airlines boeing 737 first officer
hobson has become a poster pilot for
access i
am living proof that it is never too
late to follow your dream
a former journalist turned human
resources executive turned stay at home
mom
hobson deferred her dream of a
professional flight career until the age
of 50. so there are a hundred thousand
people who fly for a living they're
seven percent who are women two to three
percent are african-american that number
has not changed in 20 years
less than one percent are black women
many of them her co-workers general
stacy harris teresa claiborne claudia
zapata cardone and andrea weeks but
before them all
there was bessie coleman so she becomes
the first american to go over to france
to receive a civilian certificate yes
she's the first black female
and yes she earned her certificate
almost two years ahead of amelia earhart
hopson's novel a pair of wings is based
on coleman's 34 years of life
mined from archives and black newspapers
of her day showcasing the aspirations of
this 20th century pioneer i began to
think about what i would be able to do
with all of this flight training when i
got home
would i truly be able to open a school
and do for the negro where in the world
would i get the airplanes even the
students with money to pay for their own
flight time for hobson looking back
allowed a way forward so we got gear
down to make coleman's dreams a reality
i was always reminded that where she
walked i had the option to take the
train
where she took the train i had the
option to fly
where she took a
ocean liner
my life was greatly improved because i
stood on her shoulders what do you hope
the book conveys to the audience the
reader hope
hope
there is never a time when you don't
have options
to dream big
and to put dates on it
to not
give up
a mirror to those aiming high and
yearning to take off very proud of you
thank you
so cool to see that relationship you
know it's been 100 years
since bessie coleman earned her pilot's
license a hundred years in june and yet
one percent of all the pilots and folks
in
the technology space of flight
are african-american women i like that
finding diamonds and watching them shine
isn't that nice yeah it is yeah